face it restrooms are gross and public
bathrooms are especially gross after all
they don't have lids on their toilet
seats so when you flush it launches a
spray of bacteria nearly 2 meters away
onto the stall walls onto the door
handle the seat everywhere now most of
these bacteria are harmless
but a few can lead to nasty infections
for example Salmonella and e-coli which
can stow away in stool and can trigger
horrible diarrhea
so beyond swearing off public restrooms
for the rest of your life
how do you stay clean you're gonna wash
away germs which might make you sick
well the obvious answer is to wash your
hands sounds easy enough right well the
sad fact is that many people don't
one-third of Americans admit that they
don't wash up after using the bathroom
and that's just the ones who admit it
and even of the ones who do wash many
don't wash the right way the CDC
recommends that you wash for twenty
seconds that's about as long as one ad
on YouTube you can manage it but about
60% of Americans reportedly wash for
only 15 seconds or less and when you do
wash you should wash with soap it's way
more effective than using just plain old
water in a 2011 study three groups of
volunteers were examined after touching
door handles and hand railings in public
spaces
the first group didn't wash at all
second washed with plain water and the
third washed with soap and water and the
results were telling the researchers
found fecal bacteria in 44% of the no
wash samples 23% of the only water
samples and a mere 8% of the soap
samples but unfortunately 70% of
Americans reportedly skipped the soap
yikes to make matters worse soap is
where things get complicated because as
it turns out not all soap is created
equal while your run-of-the-mill soap
can't hurt antibacterial soap comes with
a nasty side effect you see your hands
are normally covered with harmless
native bacteria some of which can
actually keep you healthy by fighting
off harmful germs but antibacterial soap
can kill off those native species
leaving you more susceptible to a nasty
infection so your best bet is to avoid
the antibacterial kind whenever possible
of course that's easier said than done
in a public restroom where you don't
have much control over the type of soap
that's available but no soap at all
isn't a great option either so clearly
it's time to start a global movement
hashtag BY OS or bring your own soap
just kidding that being said no matter
what your soap situation might be you're
still better off using a public restroom
than holding it in because while the
occasional potty dance won't hurt you
building a habit of holding it in for
long periods can stretch out the muscles
you use to control your bladder and over
many many years this can lead to leaking
or even infections and other issues so
it's probably worth it to brave that
stadium restroom at half time just you
know wash your hands afterward please
[Music]